und 200 Milliarden will die Regierung
für die Krise ausgeben eine mega Summe
und doch bleibt ein Zweifel wenn alle
Bürger und Unternehmen die im Moment in
echter Not sind etwas davon bekommen
dann kann selbst so ein Betrag zu gering
sein und wenn wirklich jeder
subventionierte Energie bekommt auch die
Reichen und die erfolgreichen wäre das
dann gerecht und bezahlbar wir müssen
reden sie merken es mit diesen Gästen
Franziska Giffey SPD Regierende
Bürgermeisterin von Berlin
der CDU-Politiker Thorsten Frey
Karen pittel Ökonomen und
Energieexperten
die Verbraucherschützerin Annabell
ölmann
und der Wirtschaftsjournalist Gerald
traufeter sie sind zu Gast bei Maybrit
Illner
und die sagt ein herzliches Willkommen
allen Gästen hier am Tisch wie schön
auch dass wir mal wieder alle an diesem
Tisch sitzen können wie schon in den
zwei vorangegangenen Sendungen
wenigstens darüber darf man sich freuen
200 Milliarden viel hilft viel aber wie
eigentlich genau
bis zu 200 Milliarden Euro das ist viel
aber viel ist bereits verplant für die
Verstaatlichung kollabierter
gasimporteure wie uneper oder VNG Bedarf
allein hier 34 Milliarden Euro
für Kredite an Unternehmen die trotz
preisstützen in Schwierigkeiten geraten
für Liquiditätshilfen an Stadtwerke und
auch für die gaspreisbremse die
explodierende Energiekosten abfedern
soll
reicht das Geld und wie viel kommt beim
Bürger an das wollten am Dienstag die
Ministerpräsidenten vom Kanzler wissen
aber vieles ist noch unklar Frust bei
der Union
die Menschen verlieren die Nerven die
Unternehmen wissen nicht mehr wie es
weitergeht es dauert einfach zu lang
und diese verteuerten Preise sind
toxische sagte er auch noch bei uns ist
die Regierende Bürgermeisterin von
Berlin Franziska Giffey sie waren bei
dieser Sitzung am Dienstag natürlich
auch dabei schauen wir mal auf das was
eigentlich alle wissen alle warten
darauf dass es von dieser Regierung
jetzt einen Vorschlag zur Senkung der
Preise gibt sowohl die Unternehmen als
auch die Städte als auch jeder einzelne
Bürger mit welchem Gaspreis kalkulieren
Sie momentan eigentlich hier in Berlin
haben Sie irgendeine Größenordnung mit
der sie gerade rechnen also plus Umlage
ohne Umlage
naja erstmal finde ich gut dass die
gasumlage gefallen ist das muss man ja
auch mal festhalten dafür haben wir uns
sehr eingesetzt und die
Ministerpräsidenten waren sich einig wir
brauchen in dieser Situation einen
Deckel einen energiepreisdecke dafür
haben wir einen einstimmigen Beschluss
gefasst so sind wir auch in die
Verhandlungen mit der Bundesregierung
gegangen und das ist erstmal Erfolg
diese Entscheidung wir gehen in ein
wirklich sehr veritablen Eingriff in den
Markt am Ende des Tages wir setzen ein
Stopp Kanal und gehen damit in
Stabilität und auch Planbarkeit und
diese wirklich historische Summe von 200
Milliarden Euro die ist jetzt die Chance
auch wirklich in die Breite zu gehen für
die Privathaushalte für die Unternehmen
aber auch für die sozialen Einrichtungen
und jetzt geht es darum dass ja richtig
dass das schnell ausgestaltet wird und
die Expertenkommission arbeitet ja
intensiv daran wir hoffen dass am Ende
des Wochenendes dann auch konkret wird
wie das umgesetzt wird wie wir es
schaffen können trotzdem auf das Energie
einsparen zu setzen und gleichzeitig den
Leuten Sicherheit zu geben die
wohnrechnung kommen allein
finanzberechnung die Jetzt ankommen die
müssen eben auch ein Stück weit
revidiert werden und diese Sicherheit
die braucht es jetzt und da brauchen wir
natürlich auch vor Ort ganz schnelle
Umsetzungswege auch für unsere Betriebe
wir haben ehrlich gesagt auch als
Redaktion erst verstanden und verstehen
müssen dass diese 200 Milliarden jetzt
nicht ausschließlich für diese
gaspreisbremse da sind sondern das eben
auch andere Aufgaben damit erfüllt
werden das werden natürlich noch Fragen
und diskutieren aber fragen erstmal
Annabell Oehlmann von der
Verbraucherzentrale in Bremen und
stellvertretende Chefin des Verbandes
ist sie auch noch diese Hoffnung dass
bald Strom und Gaspreise williger werden
vor allem die Gaspreise werden die haben
die Leute natürlich jetzt alle bis es
soweit hilft hilft einem dann jetzt der
Dispokredit oder was sagt die
Verbraucherschützerin all den Anrufern
das wenn es geht wirklich auf gar keinen
Fall die Menschen sind wirklich
verzweifelt und kommen mit ganz
unterschiedlichen Fragestellungen zu uns
die einen wollen sanieren kriegen aber
die Anträge nicht hin oder die
Bedingungen werden ständig geändert wir
haben aber auch viele Menschen die haben
schon vorher gespart und kommen jetzt
einfach überhaupt nicht mehr zurecht die
können nichts mehr einsparen und das
wichtigste ist wirklich in dem Moment wo
ich selber nicht weiterkomme um Hilfe
fragen um Hilfe bitten staatliche
Unterstützungen Anspruch nehmen sich an
die Verbraucherzentrale wenden und auf
gar keinen Fall dafür in den Dispo gehen
nicht in den Dispo gehen jetzt sind
viele Briefe ja schon raus auch das
haben uns hier schon Bürger
Verbraucherschützer erzählt in der
Sendung in denen diese gasumlage drin
steht und in dem die Verteuerung
drinsteht was macht man da jetzt
zerreißt man diese Post einfach oder
Bremen wird auf jeden Fall nichts
abgezogen in dem Moment da haben die
Stadtwerke sofort gesagt machen wir
nicht alles wird erstmal auf Stopp
gestellt also vorbildlich gehandelt bei
allen anderen gehe ich davon aus dass
sie ähnlich damit umgehen oder
spätestens danach dann zurückzahlen ich
würde mich immer wenn ich betroffen bin
in dem Moment an die Stadtwerke vor Ort
einmal wenden und im Zweifel meinen
Abschlag auf entsprechender Höhe von der
vorzahlen ja wir freuen uns dass Karin
pittel auch bei uns ist sie ist Ökonomen
besonders spezialisiert auf
energie-institut und sie sitzen Frau
Professor Pickel in dieser großen
gaspreisfindungskommission ein Bord mit
50 Buchstaben und versuchen nun eine
Lösung dieses überhaupt nicht einfach
ein Problems zu finden sie können da
jetzt noch keine Ergebnisse mitteilen
aber Montag kommender Woche am 10.10
soll es eine erste
Pressekonferenz geben können Sie uns die
Größenordnung sagen in der sie denken
wie groß wird ungefähr die Entlastung
für die Menschen sein 70 30 80 20 also
in welcher Größenordnung wird die
Erhöhung tatsächlich für die Menschen
gedämpft werden das kann man im Prinzip
so pauschal auch nicht sagen weil wir
auch diskutieren wie die Instrumente
genau ausgestaltet werden und da kann
man natürlich verschiedene an
verschiedenen Parametern wenn man so
möchte drehen also wie hoch ist der
Referenzpreis den ich Ansätze quasi als
als normal als sockelpreis genommen
welchen Prozentsatz würde ich quasi
verbilligen weil wir können nicht das
Gas komplett für alle über alle
Unternehmen und alle Haushalte auf den
alten Preis zurückführen dafür reicht
das Geld dann auch wieder nicht aus das
heißt es gilt eine Lösung zu finden die
zugleich sozial gerecht ist den Finanzen
gerecht wird möglichst zielgenau dann
ist aber auch technisch umsetzbar ist
das ist ja auch eine Herausforderung
jetzt tatsächlich in der Kürze der Zeit
eine Lösung zu finden die all diesen
Kriterien so gut wie möglich gerecht
wird aber auch realisierbar ist denn wir
können ja auch bestimmte Daten zum
Beispiel nicht zusammenführen weil es
auch Datenschutz gibt das heißt also ich
weiß eigentlich gar nicht wer der arme
sehr viel Gas verbrauchende Haushalt ist
ich weiß wer wie sehr viel Gas
verbraucht ich weiß auch wer arm ist
aber beides zusammen was man ja
eigentlich wissen möchte das weiß ich
nicht insofern gibt es Grenzen was man
machen kann und insofern ist die Aufgabe
dann eben das möglichst geschickt zu
machen und gleichzeitig und das
natürlich die Herausforderung unbedingt
die Anreize zum gasparen auch zu
erhalten weil sonst ist auch noch
größere Probleme
wir werden das im Detail noch ein
bisschen besser verstehen und Fragen
aber natürlich nun den Klassiker sind
dankbar dass Gerald drauf hätte
geschätzter vom Kollege vom Spiegel bei
uns ist Herr drauf hätte sie wissen
immer noch ein bisschen mehr als die
anderen Journalisten Kollegen was denken
sie sind das jetzt die vier Prozent
weniger vom
Kilowattstunden von dem vom Gaspreis
oder sind fünf Prozent oder 4 Cent oder
5 Cent weniger über welche Größenordnung
Einsparung können wir reden weil es
einen bestimmten Geldbetrag zur
Verfügung gibt also ich bin natürlich
nicht Mitglied und das gibt mir den
Vorteil dass ich darüber auch ein
bisschen sprechen kann frau Wittel kann
das nicht so wie ich das verstehe ist
tatsächlich das große Problem wir müssen
jetzt etwas ganz schnell auf die Beine
stellen im Prinzip soll ja diese
gaspreisbremse diese Reduzierung für die
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger schon im
November sich auszahlen und da kommt
eigentlich im Prinzip erstmal jetzt für
den für den Anfang nur so ein Modell in
Frage wo man ein Rabatt gewährt das ist
so ein bisschen nicht ganz so wie die
wie der tankrab hat aber
nicht dass man wahrscheinlich sagt okay
wir nehmen einfach mal vier Cent von dem
Kilowattstundenpreis runter also ich
nehme jetzt mal der
Durchschnittspreis ungefähr den die
Deutschen Zahlen der ist glaube ich bei
14 Cent gerade für die Kilowattstunde da
wird dann bis zu vier Cent vielleicht
runtergerechnet dann kommt die
Mehrwertsteuer noch
so für den Familie ungefähr noch mal so
300 400 Euro und dann kann sich das
jeder so ein bisschen jetzt versuchen
anhand seiner Gasrechnung selber
auszuholen also früher haben die Leute
ja gar nicht gewusst wie viel Gas wie
viel sie fürs aber momentan glaube ich
wissen die Leute das und der ist ein
Drittel weniger ungefähr fürs Gas und
weil sie andeuten gerade dass das eine
sehr schnelle und kurzfristige Lösung
ist ursprünglich gedacht war ja Frau
pittel hat es erwähnt dass wir mitten im
Sockelbetrag Stützen aber alles das was
drüber geht eben um auch einen
Spareffekt zu haben dann anders aussieht
ist es wirklich in so einem ersten
Schritt wenn ich sie richtig verstehe
also ich darf den ersten Schritt ist das
tatsächlich nicht möglich und da ist
eben dieser Rabatte vielleicht eine ganz
elegante einen ganz eleganter Ausweg
aber er ist teuer also da die Summen die
ich da so gesehen habe in diesen Zetteln
die da jeder einreichen konnte der
Mitglied dieser Kommission ist da
standen so 65 Milliarden das heißt also
wenn wir uns eben an ihre Rechnung
erinnern die Uhr läuft da ganz schön
schnell rund rückwärts das heißt wir
hätten eben für ein Jahr 65 verbraucht
und hätten dann maximal noch ein
dreiviertel Jahr wenn wir alle anderen
Aufgaben gedacht aus diesen 200
Milliarden auch noch erfüllen wollen
Torsten frei ist bei uns erster
parlamentarischer der Unionsfraktion ich
habe sie nicht grundlos als letzten dran
genommen weil keiner drängelt mehr als
die Opposition im Parlament und sie
erklären uns jetzt ist ihnen also
gerecht egal und ist ihnen sozial egal
es soll immer schnell gehen überhaupt
nicht ich meine das beschrieben hat ist
ja gerade das Problem die Lösung die
jetzt im Raum zu stehen scheint die ist
nicht zielgenau sie sendet nicht das
richtige Preissignal es ist nicht
gerecht und es ist im Grunde genommen
auch keine Lösung die auch gegen
Inflation wirken kann und das Schlimme
gestatten Sie mir einfach diese
Bemerkung das schlimme ist diesen
Zeitdruck hätten wir ja nicht unbedingt
nötig gehabt die Frau Professor Weber
hat diesen preisdeckel oder diesen
bürgerbasistarif bereits im Frühjahr
vorgeschlagen
eine politische im Bundestag bereits im
Frühsommer thematisiert und die
Bundesregierung hat eben ein Vierteljahr
mit der gasumlage verbraucht die jetzt
nicht kommt Gott sei Dank aber da ist
sehr viel Energie verloren gegangen und
wenn man sieht dass beispielsweise
Frankreich schon im Oktober letzten
Jahres so etwas wie ein Gaspreis und
auch ein Strompreis eingeführt hat da
muss man einfach sagen wir sind jetzt
wahnsinnig spät dran und deswegen ist es
tatsächlich so Geschwindigkeit ist ein
Thema ich glaube wir können weder die
Betriebe noch die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
bis weit in den November warten lassen
mit einer Lösung denn das Thema dass wir
jetzt haben die Bundesregierung hat
einen Abwehrschirm ins Schaufenster
gestellt 200 Milliarden Euro das hört
sich gut an aber während die Bürger
jetzt im Regen stehen probiert die
Bundesregierung gerade diesen Schirm
aufzuspannen und dafür Kriterien zu
finden da helfen sie ja mit dass das
möglichst vernünftige Kriterien werden
aber das ist eine Situation wo man
wirklich sagen muss es ist zu spät und
deswegen ist die Geschwindigkeit jetzt
wirklich ein großes Thema wie oft haben
Sie Olaf Scholz auf der Matte gestanden
im Sommer und haben gesagt lieber Olaf
bisschen Gas geben im doppelten Sinne
ich finde ja immer wenn man eine Lösung
schon kritisiert bevor die
Expertenkommission die überhaupt
erarbeitet hat finde ich es interessant
ja ich finde das ist auch unser Problem
bei dieser ganzen Diskussion dass wir
immer erwarten
dass ohne auch nur ein paar Tage des
Nachdenkens und erarbeitens die Lösung
fertig auf den Tisch liegt und ich
glaube es ist jetzt einfach wichtig den
Experten auf diese Zeit zu geben wir
haben die Erwartungshaltung dass ein
riesiger Betrag von 200.000 Millionen
Euro sinnvoll eingesetzt
werden teilweise den Bezug ja verloren
was eigentlich Milliardenbeträge
bedeuten und es ist ja auch so dass die
Bundesregierung ja in den vergangenen
Monaten sehr viel getan hat um erstmal
das zu sichern was dann verteilt wird
nämlich die Gasspeicher zu füllen und
wir hatten eigentlich die Zielsetzung
dass 90 Prozent gasspeicherbefüllung im
November erreicht sind es ist jetzt
schon erreicht das ist sehr gut und es
geht eben darum ist auch mal frei sie
müssen es auch wenn es nach ihnen
gegangen wäre hätten wir einen Gas im
Bago gehabt da wären dann die
gastspeicher leer gewesen jetzt und den
Herrn März dann schon vollständig
zitieren ich meine wissen wir haben ja
viele Diskussionen auch um die
erneuerbaren Energien und wer die dann
befürwortet und befördert aber das
müssen wir jetzt auch gar nicht machen
ich glaube den Leuten geht es nicht um
parteipolitisches Gezänke sondern die
Situation ist wie sie ist die
Bundesregierung hat eine Entscheidung
getroffen für ein historischen
Abwehrschirm 200 Milliarden Euro und die
Kommission hat jetzt wenige Tage Zeit um
zu erarbeiten wie das aussieht ich finde
es absolut richtig es muss wirksam und
zielgenau sein und es muss so sein dass
eben der Anreiz zum Energiesparen nicht
verloren geht das wird essentiell sein
sonst kommen wir nämlich mit dem Bestand
der Fürsprecher auch immer die Frage und
das war der Vorwurf der Opposition wenn
wir viel früher als eben jetzt ab
September angefangen hätten über diese
gaspreisbremse nachzudenken dann hätten
wir vielleicht jetzt schon eine Lösung
die in anderen Ländern funktioniert also
Spanien Frankreich es ist ja nicht nur
Frankreich die Spanier machen das
längste wird der Preis gedeckelt bei den
Bürgern kommen vier bis zehn Prozent
Erhöhung überhaupt nur an bitte die
können wir ja diskutieren in Spanien ist
es schief gegangen bei den Franzosen die
da kann man anderes kritisieren aber da
hat eine Regierung sofort dafür gesorgt
dass eine energiepreiserhöhung bei 4%
bleibt im Jahr also ganz kurz noch mal
die Frage es ist auch ein richtiger
Punkt dafür haben wir uns als Länder ja
auch stark gemacht ich finde gut dass es
jetzt so ist und ich finde auch gut dass
diese gasumlage gefallen ist das hätte
man sich sparen können zweimal im
Deutschen Bundestag beantragt und die
Koalition hat es zweimal abgelehnt im
September noch also so ich will nur noch
mal zu Herrn Merz sagen von nur
Akkuratesse nochmal zu dem was hat Herr
März gesagt und was hat die Opposition
gefordert ich glaube es war ihre
Pressekonferenz CDU CSU eben auch eben
März des Jahres 22 es viel auf jeden
Fall auch der Satz bevor uns andere oder
Herr Putin das Gas abstellen sollten wir
die Gaslieferungen durch nordstream 1
beenden also ich will jetzt nicht
wegmesserisch sein oder irgendwie da bei
der zweite Teil des Satzes war das
Friedrich Merz darauf hingewiesen hat so
weit wir andere Bezugsmöglichkeiten aus
Russland haben also Friedrich Merz hat
nie ein Embargo gefordert er hat gesagt
das Lieferung
eines einstellen und er hat nicht gesagt
wenn wir sondern wir haben andere
Bezugsquellen so war die korrekte
Formulierung Blick zurück wir wollen
präzise sein wir gucken nach vorne Herr
drauf hätte und sagen und fragen
wir sind ja tatsächlich auf die Idee
gekommen Stichwort auf diese Situation
jetzt noch eine gasumlage oben drauf zu
packen wie konnte das denn sein ich will
jetzt nicht um die gasumlage reden
sondern ich will nur sagen in einer
Situation in der andere Regierung in
Europa längst die Idee kamen Preise zu
senken für die Verbraucher wollten wir
noch eins drauf tun wie kam das also der
Gedanke der gasumlage war ja eigentlich
diesen Konzern uniper der in großer
Bedrängnis war zu stützen und das ist
auch glaube ich allgemein anerkannt dass
das wichtig gewesen wäre weil wir sonst
da also eine Art Lehman Brothers Effekt
gehabt hätten also
Juniper beliefert Stadtwerke wenn
Juniper kein Gas mehr liefert stehen die
ohne Gas da und können die Kunden nicht
mehr beliefern das war klar da muss
etwas geschehen und da war die Idee wir
machen das mit so einer gasumlage dann
hat man dann später als
dann der die Kritik so groß war gesagt
na gut wir nehmen dieses Geld aus dem
Staatshaushalt und das hätte man im
Prinzip schon viel früher machen müssen
viel früher machen können und müssen bei
Lufthansa oder ansonsten auch bei Banken
bereits hatten es war ja nichts Neues
sozusagen also gasumlage und diese
gaspreisbremse in zwei verschiedene
Dinge das muss man so ein bisschen
versuchen in der Diskussion zu trennen
weil den Preis noch erhöhen weil
Christian Lindner irgendwie die Steuern
nicht zahlen wollte und offensichtlich
auch Robert Habeck ich weiß nicht die
Grünen waren ja auch beteiligt daran die
haben offensichtlich auch gedacht dass
diese gasumlage eine Möglichkeit ist um
auch mal zu schauen ob die Bürger sparen
ob die Bürger damit dann diesen anderen
ich suche immer noch nach der
politischen Erklärung tue ich auch noch
also meine These dazu ist das die eine
Seite also Habeck und sein Ministerium
tatsächlich diesen Gedanken folgen
wollten wir brauchen ein Preissignal
also höhere Preise verleiten dazu dass
man spart die industriespart die Kunden
sparen und auf der anderen Seite bei
Christian Lindner war halt eben diese
große Angst diese die Schuldenbremse
abzuholen das ist ja irgendwie so ein
wahlkampfschlager also er denkt
zumindest das ist ein wahlkampfschlager
und die ist noch nicht aufgegeben genau
wird immer noch weiter diskutiert und
ich glaube da kam diese beiden Sachen
zusammen und
und dann die gasumlage raus und die ist
jetzt zum Glück Weg genau und ich glaube
da hätte einfach dann der Kanzler glaube
ich mal auf den Tisch hauen müssen und
sagen sollen so jetzt so jetzt haben sie
diese erste Stufe annotiert die nächste
muss man sich dann her drauf hätte wie
vorstellen dann würde man probieren dass
auch gerechter zu machen und nicht mehr
nur mit so einem Rabatt an alle ja also
die zweite Stufe ich weiß ich will das
natürlich jetzt nicht vorwegnehmen was
was sie da vielleicht noch anderes
herausfinden aber ich denke es wird sich
so dann einspielen dass man sagt also im
nächsten Jahr wird man einen
kontingentlösung machen also der
Verbraucher darf zum Beispiel 80 Prozent
zu einem subventionierten preisgas
beziehen und den Rest muss er dann zu
den dann handelsüblichen höheren Preisen
zahlen man kann das variieren man kann
70 sagen und 30 und so weiter aber so
und da bleibt natürlich dann für die
meisten doch ein sehr großer Anreiz
weiter zu sparen das ist die eigentlich
sinnvollere Lösung die ist aber
offensichtlich so sagen dann die die
Stadtwerke und die die Energiewirtschaft
wahnsinnig kompliziert da sagen die das
schaffen wir nicht in diesem Monat das
auf die Beine zu stellen Fragen wir Frau
also ich möchte klären erklären
sozusagen vier Tage oder fünf Tage bevor
wir tatsächlich die Ergebnisse der
Absprachen und der
Überlegungen vorstellen jetzt zu
hypothetisieren was wahrscheinlich dabei
rauskommt weil da werden auch wieder
Erwartungen geweckt die vielleicht
nachher kommt vielleicht dann doch
anders als mein jetzt gedacht hätte wenn
was wichtig ist das haben sie gerade
noch mal darauf hingewiesen was am
Montag kommt ist ja quasi jetzt erstmal
wirklich die kurze fest und dann haben
wir ja noch bis Ende des Monats
tatsächlich auch noch weiter darüber
hinaus nachzudenken aber trotzdem würde
ich jetzt vorsichtig sein mit dem man
die vier Tage kann man jetzt auch noch
warten was dabei rauskommt und ich
glaube sie scheinen sehr viel Einsichten
zu haben die mir schon leicht unheimlich
sind also was Sie gesagt haben dass sie
Zettel gesehen haben und all sowas aber
trotzdem waren sie natürlich in Sitzung
nicht dabei und die verlaufen sehr
konstruktiv und ich würde jetzt erstmal
abwarten was dabei raus so aber dann
sind wir doch mal nicht unfair Frau
Pickel und sagen in dieser Situation
damit haben sie gerade gerechnet Hoppler
was wäre ihr präferiertes Modell das
können sie ja unumwunden sagen weil das
vertreten sie ja also ich wäre auf jeden
Fall wie viele Ökonomen auch wenn eine
Kontingent Lösung also dass man im
Prinzip wirklich sagt man hat einen
bestimmten grundkonsum der schon eine
gewisse Einsparung auch mit beinhaltet
und man dann tatsächlich auch eine
Subventionierung
quasi durchführt das heißt die bekommt
man günstiger diese Einheiten und ob das
dann quasi für jede einzelne Einheit
abgerechnet wird oder ob man diese Summe
einfach
aufs Konto bekommt quasi wie auch immer
das dann technisch gelöst wird das würde
rein rechnerisch auf genau das gleiche
herausführen also das wäre mir dann den
Vorteil dass die Menschen dann frei
darüber verfügen können und entscheiden
also wenn sie sagen sie möchten diesen
Betrag Geldes also ich finde mir wäre es
lieber aber dass ich wirklich den
Menschen quasi diesen Betrag gebe dann
können Sie selber entscheiden ob sie es
wirklich für Gas oder ob sie quasi ich
war jetzt nicht ich nehme das Geld und
nimmst für Gas oder ich nehme es für was
anderes wäre mir lieber aber so eine
kontingentlösung ist auf jeden Fall
etwas sehr vernünftiges und damit kann
man eben dann die einspar Anreize auch
aufrecht erhalten ich denkbar ist ja
auch eine Kombination aus beidem man
muss zwar aufpassen dass es nicht zu
komplex wird aber ich glaube es ist ganz
entscheidend dass dieses Preissignal
bleibt und das ist bewältigbar bleibt
für die Menschen das ist das damit man
Verlässlichkeit schafft aber zum anderen
wenn man sieht wir haben zwar gut
gefüllte Gasspeicher das stimmt und
trotzdem brauchen wir eine Einsparung
von 22 Prozent gegenüber dem
historischen Gasverbrauch und wenn man
sieht was die Bundesnetzagentur gesagt
hat dass nicht nur bei der Industrie die
Einsparungen wieder zurückgegangen sind
jetzt auf nur noch zwei Prozent das im
Bereich der privaten sogar
ein anderes Thema Entschuldigung möchte
jetzt erstmal ganz kurz Frau Oehlmann
bei der Frage bleiben was wäre denn
gerecht was würden Menschen auch gerecht
empfinden alsgerecht empfinden man
könnte sich orientieren am Vorjahr aber
auch da gäbe es ja Faktoren die man
beeinflussen kann und nicht beeinflussen
kann das Wetter Menschen sind leider
nicht der Mensch ich befürchte da gibt
es nicht die eine Antwort je nachdem wie
man selber sozusagen den Verbrauch hat
würde es hier zu unterschiedlichen
Antworten führen ich persönlich denke
einfach diese Krise wird uns alle eine
Menge Geld kosten ein Teil von uns kann
dieses Geld tragen und braucht keine
oder wenig Unterstützung und es gibt
aber auch einen ganzen Teil dieser
Gesellschaft die werden das nicht
schaffen genauso bei den Unternehmen
gerade bei den kleinen die werden
richtig Unterstützung und auch mehr
Unterstützung brauchen und aus meiner
Sicht wäre gerecht wenn wir denen die es
brauchen mehr helfen als die in die es
wirklich nicht brauchen und das hatten
wir bei allen anderen entlastungspaketen
auch es wurde pauschal ausgezahlt und
das ist total suboptimal es muss
wirklich an der richtigen Stelle und da
auch genug ankommen weil das ist das
andere Problem also das würde eben auch
dafür sprechen dass man sagt man guckt
nachher nicht nur aus Gas sondern
Produkt eben auch insgesamt auf die
energiepreiserhöhung und kombiniert das
zum Beispiel mit einer anderen
Entlastung die dann für alle ist weil
das ist jetzt erstmal Gas weil Gas
einfach extrem gestiegen ist aber da
haben wir eben das Problem dass wir
nicht differenzieren können wie reich
sind die Haushalte die wir jetzt
eigentlich treffen und das ist immer die
Diskussion um die reihensorger wüssten
das Vermieter wissen dass manchmal
stimmt die kennen nur natürlich den
Verbraucher nach dem Verbrauch Fragen
und da kann man natürlich darauf
schließen ist das jetzt irgendwie man
sieht auch an den Häusern ob es
Einfamilienhaus ist oder ob da sie
Familienwohnung
es gibt die Info die Informationen sind
alle draußen aber man darf sie nicht man
darf sie auch nicht unbedingt ich möchte
nicht wissen dass mein Versorger weiß
wie viel ich verdiene mir ist es
wahrscheinlich egal aber es muss also
das ist das ist erstmal ein
grundsätzliches Problem und dann kommt
eben die Diskussion natürlich auch wenn
man sagt man macht auch zum Beispiel
Rabatt sondern haben natürlich die die
viel verbrauchen viel mehr davon als die
die weniger brauchen und dann kommt die
Diskussion um den solchen willenbesitzer
mit dem mit dem mit dem Swimmingpool der
wahrscheinlich genauso viel Gas
verbraucht wie der arme Haushalt auf dem
Lande in einem großen aber umgelenten
Haus
wenn ich den gern entlassen möchte jetzt
kennen das Einkommen aber nicht dann
werde ich den leider mitnehmen müssen
also das sind einfach alles Konstrukte
wo man wirklich überlegen muss wie geht
man damit um und die Armen möchte man ja
nur gerade auch
andere staatliche Hilfe brauche muss ich
auch sehr viele Angaben machen sehr
viele Zettel ausfüllen sehr viel an also
das ist ein gutes Argumenten vielleicht
auch nicht anderen Unternehmen aber in
dem Staat muss ich schon Angaben machen
langfristig er hat nur bei allem was wir
da tun glaube ich ist die Frage der
Umsetzbarkeit sehr wichtig welche
Behörden sollen das tun wie sind die
ausgestattet wir haben jetzt die
Diskussion um die wohngelderhöhung den
für die Verdreifachung des
empfängerkreises wollte ich gerade
fragen also werden entschuldigung das
diskutieren die Menschen nämlich und
möchten gerne wissen ob wenn es denn zu
diesen gaspreisbremsen käme und sogar zu
einer strompreisbremse würde es denn bei
der wohngelderhöhung bleiben das ist
also bleiben die
aber bleiben die also bleibt dann diese
Wohngeld Auswahlkreis wirklich dann also
das muss man sehen wie wie dann die
Entwicklung geht also die
grundsatzpolitische Entscheidung dass
der Empfängerkreis ausgeweitet werden
soll daran arbeiten wir das wird der
vorbereitet die Frage ist eben und das
ist ja in der kommunizierende Röhren
wenn der Deckel jetzt wirklich wirkt
dann kann es sein dass weniger Menschen
in die Situation kommen Wohngeld
beantragen zu müssen das wäre ja gut ja
so überlegen wir auch wir haben in
Berlin beispielsweise ein eigenes
Entlastungspaket beschlossen zwischen
800 Millionen 1,5 Milliarden Euro wo wir
sechs Einzelmaßnahmen drin haben die in
die Wirtschaft gehen die in die
Privathaushalte gehen die aber auch in
die sozialen Einrichtungen gehen und
auch zum Beispiel unser Anschlussticket
fürs 9 Euro Ticket ist dabei ein Thema
ja
ich finde es ganz wichtig das war sowas
auch diskutieren wie kommen wie kommen
die Maßnahmen bei den Leuten an und eins
ist doch ganz klar wenn dafür Ellen
lange Anträge ausgefüllt werden müssen
wenn die Hürden zu hoch sind um da rein
zu kommen dann werden weniger Menschen
davon profitieren
weil wir Zeit verschlafen haben machen
wir jetzt eine rabattlösung wo auf der
reiche erfolgreich gehen wir mal davon
aus gehen
liebe Frau pittel und der Kommission
jede Chance der Welt aber wahrscheinlich
wird die kurzfristlösung erstmal eine
nicht nur kurzfristige sondern eine alle
treffende Lösung sein das heißt auch für
den erfolgreichen und sozial werden wir
dann später
direkt daran diese Regierung schon also
man muss jetzt vielleicht auch mal
einfach schauen was wir wollen also wir
haben eine Notsituation ja und in dieser
Notsituation wo Menschen die Sorge haben
die Unternehmen nicht weiterführen zu
können bleibt würde ich immer erstmal
und das haben wir bei Corona auch
gemacht da gab es die Soforthilfen die
verhindert haben es gibt viele Betriebe
auch in Berlin die mir sagen hätten wir
das damals nicht so schnell bekommen
dann gäbe es uns heute gar nicht mehr
und darum muss es gehen wenn wir sagen
das war aber ein sehr einfach der Antrag
es ging total easy da haben sich dann
auch wieder Menschen aufgeregt wenn
Leute Missbrauch getrieben haben aber da
muss man sagen wer Missbrauch betreibt
die Mühlen der Finanzämter meint
vielleicht manchmal langsam aber dann
doch auch sehr genau und das wird er
dann im nachhinein kann das ja auch ein
Stück weit ausgeglichen werden ich würde
immer sagen wir müssen jetzt verhindern
dass Menschen in die Pleite gehen in die
Insolvenz und das Betrieb und ein
bisschen gefuscht nein nicht gefuscht
aber die Priorität ist die Schnelligkeit
und dann geht es natürlich darum dass
man das Ziel genau macht und deswegen
ist es doch richtig eine kurzfrist
Lösung jetzt zu überlegen und dann aber
ein Modell was auch länger trägt denn
eins muss ja klar sein dieser
gaspreisdeckel der wird nicht ein paar
Monate gehen der wird vielleicht ich
weiß nicht was sie planen aber also zwei
Jahre sicherlich und vielleicht sogar
länger so lange bis wir eben nicht
interessante interessanter Punkte frei
hier ist die Frage Christian Lindner
höchst selbst hat in der Vorstellung
dieses superwumms doppelwumms darauf
aufmerksam gemacht dass man für Corona
600 Milliarden in die Hand genommen hat
und zur Rettung der Banken 500
Milliarden und es gibt eine Opposition
die weiß jeden dritten Tag darauf hin
dass man jetzt zwar den Menschen schnell
helfen sollte aber keine Schulden machen
soll sehen sie da einen kleinen desenz
wenn sie auf der einen Seite sagen auf
gar keinen Fall die Schuldenbremse
lockern und auf der anderen Seite sagen
warum habt ihr das nicht längst
rausgehauen und wir wollen mehr also die
Schuldenbremse ab dem nächsten Jahr ist
es eine die Tatsache dass die
Bundesregierung dieses Jahr 500
Milliarden Euro neue Schulden machen
wird das ist also fast das Zweifache
eines normalen Bundeshaushaltes das
zeigt doch dass enorm viel Geld
ausgegeben wird zur Bekämpfung dieser
Krise der Staat nimmt ja auch enorm viel
ein ja er hat zumindest in diesem Jahr
erhebliche Steuer Mehreinnahmen sowohl
bei den direkten wie auch bei den
indirekten Steuern das ist vollkommen
richtig ja das trifft den Staat genauso
wie die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
er muss ja Geld in die Hand nehmen er
muss es ja finanzieren oder wo würden
sie es her nehmen er muss Geld in die
Hand nehmen das tut er ja auch ich meine
diese 200 Milliarden über die wir
sprechen das sind Schulden die dieses
Jahr aufgenommen werden genauso wie das
Sondervermögen für die Bundeswehr
Schulden sind und genauso wie die
Verschuldung die der Staat im laufenden
Haushalt ohnehin macht würden sie alles
nicht machen die Opposition machen nein
wenn man es richtig macht dann ist es in
Ordnung das müssen wir uns eben genau
anschauen sehen Sie das Problem ist es
werden jetzt mal 200 Milliarden Euro in
Schaufenster gestellt wir diskutieren
jetzt darüber wie die expertenvorschläge
dazu sind wenn die expertenvorschläge
vorliegen dann muss ich der Bundestag
und der Bundesrat noch damit
beschäftigen und ich finde eigentlich
hätte man es ja umgekehrt machen können
man hätte ja überlegen können was ist
das richtige Instrument um diese Krise
zu bekämpfen dann schaut man was es
kostet was man dafür braucht und dann
überlegt man ob das ein richtiger
Mitteleinsatz ist das wäre die richtige
Vorgehensweise gewesen die leben wir
aber hier nicht meine mir geht so ein
bisschen so das ist alles richtig und
sind sicherlich Fehler gemacht worden
aber ich glaube wir sollten jetzt auch
in so einer Situation uns noch mal
vergegenwärtigen warum machen wir das
eigentlich warum nehmen wir eigentlich
jetzt so viel Geld in die Hand letztlich
geht es ja darum den sozialen Frieden in
Deutschland zu bewahren denn Putin hat
ja ganz klar erklärt er will unsere
Wirtschaft treffen er will auch unser
Land auseinander dividieren und deswegen
glaube ich müssen wir sehr sehr viel
Geld in die Hand nehmen und müssen
vielleicht auch sagen wir mal den ein
oder anderen Fehler uns verzeihen der
der gemacht wurde und dann jetzt zur
Lösung kommt den sozialen Frieden kann
man sicherlich Stützen indem man sozial
gerecht vorgeht und dann bin ich noch
mal bei der Frage die wir bis jetzt
schon angesprochen aber noch nicht
vielleicht vollständig gewendet haben es
gibt ja auch Ökonomen Frau pittel Herr
Bratscher ist einer von ihnen die sagen
auch mit diesen 200 Milliarden was immer
bekommt werden wir Geringverdiener in
diesem Land nicht ausreichend helfen wir
werden die die nicht Hartz4 Empfänger
sind die nicht stützempfänger sind die
2000 3000 Euro verdienen sicherlich
nicht damit durch den Monat kommen
lassen und dann ist das Geld ja aber
eigentlich weg so also wie ist in einer
möglichen
Folgemaßnahme dann gesichert dass wir
sozial gerechter werden also ich finde
die diese 200 Milliarden sich da quasi
zu festzulegen hat viele Vorteile aber
auch viele Nachteile ich meine dass die
Zahl überhaupt genannt wurde ist denke
ich einfach zu Beruhigung gewesen der
Beruhigung da wird auch nicht in die
Hand ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht
weil ich finde es schwierig tatsächlich
etwas festzulegen wo man eigentlich noch
gar nicht weiß was man tatsächlich
ausgeben sollte und bräuchte und dann zu
sagen 200 Milliarden andererseits ist
das glaube ich in dieser Signal gewesen
einfach an die Gesellschaft an die
Wirtschaft hier kommt was Großes zur
Beruhigung also ich glaube das sind die
nicht zum Sparen an oder jetzt kommt
darauf an wie man es macht also da bin
ich das das glaube ich nicht aber
einfach das was unternommen wird das
tatsächlich etwas gemacht wird also das
insofern finde ich die 200 Milliarden
aber auch schwierig in der Hinsicht dass
man jetzt sagt ja wenn die alle sind
dann haben wir ja nichts mehr das stimmt
ja auch so nicht an die anderen drei
entlastungspakete die 300 Euro
energiepauschale die Rentner die
Studierenden
da kommt es natürlich dann darauf an
dass man es tatsächlich auch Instrumente
so ausgestaltet dass tatsächlich auch
nur die Geringverdiener entweder die
Geringverdiener oder eben auch Hartz IV
Empfänger und so weiter tatsächlich auch
Geld bekommen und da können wir uns eben
nicht dann immer leisten dass wir
Pauschalbeträge zum Beispiel an jedem
an jeden geben ich habe jetzt gerade
meine 300 bekommen
ja werde ich auch also das habe ich auch
von vornherein gesagt aber ich habe sie
gerade erst entdeckt also ein neues Lied
passiert aber wenn man im Prinzip
einfach überlegt dass man 300 an jeden
gibt oder man gibt dem Drittel den
Ärmsten Drittel nur 1.000 oder man
braucht mehr also deshalb Vorschlag auch
von Friedrich Merz und der Union vor
allem die Frage wenn die Gemeinden
sparen dann sparen Sie natürlich bei
Schwimmbädern sie sparen bei
Bibliotheken sie sparen vielleicht auch
im ÖPNV und da treffe es ja wieder die
die insgesamt fleißig sind und zu wenig
im Portemonnaie genau und vor allem
keine Zeit mehr haben die Menschen
stehen wirklich zum Teil mit dem Rücken
zur Wand die kommen jetzt schon nicht
mehr zurecht wir haben in Beratung
suizidandrohung von Menschen weil sie
nicht wissen wie es weitergeht und auf
der anderen Seite haben aber auch ganz
viele die noch gar nicht erkennen wie
schlimm es wirklich ist wie hoch die
Zinsen im Baufinanzierungsbereich gehen
werden wenn die Anschlussfinanzierung im
nächsten Jahr junge Familien die hoch
verschuldet sind und die faktisch da an
ihre Grenzen kommen werden wir haben
sanierungswillige die aber wiederum
ständig vor geänderten Rahmenbedingungen
stehen Förderanträgen und so weiter und
so fort im Moment ist das Hauptproblem
glaube ich dass die Menschen das Gefühl
haben hin her rechts links wir wissen
nicht wo es hingeht und die
Verlässlichkeit fehlt an der Stelle und
ich verstehe die Zeit ich gebe Ihnen die
vier Tage wirklich gerne das ist
überhaupt nicht die Frage an der Stelle
und haben auch große Hoffnungen in die
Richtung aber es ist wirklich so dass
viele im Moment das Gefühl haben selbst
wenn etwas zu einem Zeitpunkt kommt es
ist zu spät so viel Zeit habe ich nicht
mehr und das ist etwas was wir glaube
ich sehr ernst nehmen müssen wir spricht
natürlich auch tatsächlich für eine
pragmatische einfache Lösung genau die
dann schnell kommen kann und inkludiert
dass es eine Legislative natürlich
braucht und auch einen
Bundesratsbeschluss reden wir für diese
schnellen Maßnahmen tatsächlich noch vom
Oktober November gehen Sie davon aus
dass es schnell und wie schnell geht
Frau wenn man so eine zweistufigkeit
Macht und erstmal gibt es eine
Soforthilfe und dann geht man in ein
Modell was längerfristig gilt glaube ich
kann man da viel erreichen und es muss
eben auch so sein dass und ich kann das
nur noch mal sagen also wenn man dieses
günstige öpnv-ticket nimmt das geht
absolut in die Breite es ist für die
Leute leicht zu bekommen sie spüren
sofort eine Entlastung sie spüren auch
Teilhabe Möglichkeiten dadurch dass sie
mobil sein können und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt da ist eben
dann dass die ländlichen Regionen sagen
ja wir brauchen aber auch das Geld um
die Strecken auszubauen ja
Regionalisierungsmittel aber man muss
Instrumente finden die schnell
verlässlich wirksam sind und die bei den
Leuten spürbar ankommen nur dann
bekommen sie auch hin dass wirklich auf
vertraut wird darin was passiert es muss
merkbar sein man muss auch Antworten
dafür finden die Rechnung kommen ja
schon die sind ja bei ihnen ich habe
auch mit unserer
Verbraucherschutzzentrale ganz intensive
Gespräche auch von Leuten die so
Trittbrettfahrer sind und jetzt der
Mondpreise aufrufen und dann quasi das
als Glücksritter diese Zeit die wir
haben da muss man natürlich gegen
vorgehen und auch Beratung anbieten und
ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass man
eine Antwort findet auf die Rechnung die
jetzt schon eingegangen sind das wäre
eine Bitte die auch an sie hätte dass
man wenn man jetzt sagt es kommt im
November was oder es kommt im Dezember
was dass man sagt die Rechnung die jetzt
eingegangen sind was machen die Leute
mit denen ja also sind die dann obsolet
und man beachtet sie erstmal nicht oder
der Hinweis ist wie sie gesagt haben
bezahlen Sie das was Sie immer bezahlt
haben und der Rest wird irgendwie
ausgeglichen ich glaube dafür braucht es
einfach ein praktischen Hinweis der auch
dann sofort trägt und ein Stück weit
auch die Sorgen nimmt wenn die hohen
Rechnungen Behinderung dann das kann man
doch nicht an der Expertenkommission
auslagernkommissionshinweise
berücksichtigen und ich gebe
schon gesagt wie sie berät indem sie
sagt ignorieren es einfach also nicht
anzünden natürlich ist nicht gut
in dem Moment kann ich ganz schnell eine
Sperre reinlaufensituation wir haben
keine Nachzahlung also Ihre Rechnung
nicht mehr bezahlen können
die Empfehlung der Verbraucherzentrale
das möchte ich an dieser Stelle nochmal
ganz klar sagen aber die Gas genau damit
umgeht ist wichtig und die brauchen
wirklich Hilfe an der Stelle gerade wenn
zu hohe Nachzahlungen sind dass sie
sonst in den Kredit gehen müssten das
auf jeden Fall und mein Tipp ist immer
nicht ignorieren nicht weglegen sondern
sofort um Hilfe Rat zu anderen gehen und
sich die holen damit man dann nach
Lösungen suchen kann aber was sagen sie
dann also wenn da jetzt ein
Familienvater von der vierköpfigen
Familie vor Ihnen sitzt und sagt ich
kriege keinen 13-gehalt ich soll eins
zahlen was sagen Sie dem das erste was
man immer machen muss ist wirklich
prüfen habe ich andere staatliche
Ansprüche viele haben aufgrund der
einmaligen hohen Anforderungen auf
einmal Anspruch auf staatliche Leistung
obwohl sie es nie vorher hatten wir
reden hier genau wir reden aber hier von
Menschen die haben noch nie staatliche
Hilfe irgendwie in Anspruch genommen die
müssen erstmal diese Hürde nehmen und
natürlich sind die Ämter auch alle
gefüllt und Termine schwer zu kriegen
aber das ist ein ganz wichtiger Schritt
das zweite ist immer dass man sofort mit
dem Versorger im Zweifel auch spricht
oder mit dem Vermieter und erstmal sagt
ich habe ein Problem ich habe hier ein
Problem und bitte drehe nicht sofort
alles ab bitte sperre mich nicht weil
dadurch explodieren die Kosten einmal
gesperrt ist viel teurer als etwas
anderes vereinbart wir haben in Bremen
dafür gute Lösungen und gute Instrumente
und wir haben auch in Bremen ein
härtefallfonds auch den kann ich dann in
Anspruch nehmen wenn es sonst keinen
anderen Weg gibt der ist natürlich nicht
für diese Krise ausgelegt den hatten wir
schon vorher und der wird jetzt
überarbeitet und angepasst entsprechend
aber wir haben zumindest
hilfsnetz und hilfswege die
funktionieren können und das glaube ich
brauchen jetzt ganz viele Kommunen und
Länder den Familienvater kann man klar
sagen Kindergeld wird ja auch erhöht
aber wirklich noch mal prüfen
Kinderzuschlag beantragen den gibt es
oben drauf aufs Kindergeld und den
bekommt man per Online-Antrag sehr
simpel kann ich Ihnen sagen das
funktioniert ganz gut und da wissen
viele nicht dass es das gibt also
insofern ist das auch sie fragen Frau
pittel noch mal für das Verständnis und
um das Verständnis diese 200 Milliarden
letzte Gedanke dazu diese 200 Milliarden
sind im übrigen auch auf drei Jahre
gerechnet da wird der
Bundesfinanzminister auch nicht müde das
zu erwähnen ne also wir haben nicht nur
eine Einschränkung in Bezug auf die
ganzen Funktionen sondern es soll für
drei Jahre gelten und jetzt sind wir in
der Situation eben nicht mehr russisches
Gas zu verfeuern sondern erstmal anderes
Gas aus anderen Quellen zu kreditieren
ihr Gefühl ihr wissen wie lange wird das
so sein dass die Gaspreise so hoch
bleiben also die Prognosen sind schon
dass die im nächsten Jahr weiter wieder
zurückgehen werden also
100 Euro 150 Euro pro Megawattstunde zum
Vergleich werden 18 vorher also vor der
Krise und wir haben jetzt ungefähr 160
und hatten schon mal 300 um das
einzuordnen so ein bisschen also es ist
schon die Erwartung dass sie wieder
runtergehen aber dass sie schon da auch
auf dem hohen Niveau dann auch bleiben
okay wir sind ich wollte sie noch nach
Donaueschingen Fragen Herr frei das ist
natürlich also sie waren neun Jahre
Bürgermeister in dieser nicht ganz
unbekannten Stadt im Süden des Landes
die Stadtwerke haben das habe ich
irgendwo gelesen tatsächlich in
Donaueschingen auch ein interessantes
Problem eine Herausforderung viele
Bürger sind zwischenzeitlich zu anderen
vermeintlich besseren hippen Anbietern
gewechselt um jetzt wieder an der Tür
der Stadtwerke zu stehen und zu sagen
bitte nehmt mich zurück ist sowas
möglich was wissen sie aus ihrer
Heimatstadt wie regelt man jetzt sowas
ja so etwas ist möglich also die
Stadtwerke sind natürlich in der Lage
sozusagen diese Preisanstiege zu dämpfen
weil sie in der Regel 24 Monate vorher
das Gas einkaufen und deswegen schlagen
die hohen Preise jetzt nicht sofort
durch aber das Problem dass sie
ansprechen ist eben wenn diejenigen die
bei irgendwelchen Online Anbietern waren
und jetzt bei den akuten
Preissteigerungen sich umschauen was
kann man tun dann gehen die zu den
Grundversorgern den Stadtwerken vor Ort
dort müssen sie auch aufgenommen werden
das bedeutet wiederum dass die
Stadtwerke mehr Gas bestellen müssen
jetzt zu den hohen Preisen die da
derzeit aufgerufen werden und das
bedeutet eben dass sozusagen für alle
dann auch der Gaspreis zwar moderat also
nicht moderat aber nicht exponentiell
jedenfalls aber steigen aber natürlich
aber ich hätte man hat nochmal den
Finger gehoben Entschuldigung wir kommen
dann wirklich geschworen zum Nähen ich
wollte nur bestätigen es ist genauso
viele nutzen die Chance auch über die
teure Ersatzversorgung die die ersten
drei Monate gilt dann in die
Grundversorgung wieder reinzukommen wir
wissen aber auch die Stadtwerke kaufen
jetzt für in zwei Jahren ein also wir
wissen wirklich die Preise werden auch
langfristig im Mittel noch gut bleiben
und natürlich nicht ja weil diejenigen
die immer die günstigen Preise genossen
haben die kommen jetzt wieder zurück zu
den Grundversorgern zu den Stadt und
bauen auf die Solidarität der
Gemeinschaft
sozusagen
absehbar dann schon noch weiter und dann
auch runter wenn die Kapazitäten
ausgebaut genau jetzt wie versprochen
oder hatten sie zu dem Punkt noch wenn
ich wollte ja einfach nur ein Aspekt
noch benennen ich will ihnen nicht
vorgreifen aber wir reden ja jetzt die
ganze Zeit immer nur über die
Umverteilung der Probleme die wir haben
wir zum Sparen und zu den Quellen
bitteschön haben wir versprochen wir
haben noch 15 Minuten wir reden alle ein
bisschen schneller also Unternehmen
wollen wir auch noch stimmt Frau pittel
Klaus Müller Bundesnetzagentur Chef
große Sorge verbrauche sinken zu wenig
teilen Sie diese Sorge sind die Bürger
dieses Landes verschwenderisch ist im
Moment noch schwer zu sagen also die
Industrie das sind die gasverbrauche
schon substantiell gesunken also mehr
als 20 Prozent im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
und bei den Haushalten ging jetzt
natürlich sehr stark durch die Presse
dass die gasverbräuche im Vergleich zum
Vorjahr höher waren wobei ich nicht
glaube dass das Witterungs angepasst war
das heißt das muss man jetzt noch mal
abwarten die Heizsaison geht wirklich
gerade erst los und im Sommer ist
einfach traditionell natürlich viel
weniger an Gasverbrauch bei den
Haushalten wir haben nicht so viel
Klimaanlagen wie andere Länder das heißt
also das geht jetzt erst richtig hoch
und man kann es nur hoffen dass eben
tatsächlich die Menschen auch vernünftig
sind also nicht nur weil die Preise
hochgehen sondern tatsächlich auch weil
sie sagen hier kann ich es beim durch
meinen Beitrag dazu beitragen dass wir
eben nicht in eine gasmangellage
bekommen wir lernen alle wahnsinnig dazu
und wir gucken gemeinsam bitte auf diese
Grafik sie ist von der Bundesnetzagentur
und ihr Chef Klaus Müller sagt wir
sparen zu wenig sie sehen hier zwei
Graphen durchgezogene Linie einmal blau
das ist das Mittel der Jahre 18 bis 2021
also von vier Jahren und die
durchgezogene rote Linie zeigt den
Verbrauch in 22 bis zum September sie
können es erkennen hier im Studio auch
die Unterscheidung in orange und rot in
den Balken das müsste ich noch erklären
weist die Industrie aus und auf der
anderen Seite private Haushalte und
Gewerbe das heißt es gibt eigentlich gar
keinen extra ausgewiesenen Wert für nur
die privaten Haushalte sondern das was
wir da lesen konnten ist immer privater
Haushalt und Gewerbe und wir sehen
erstaunlicherweise ich weiß nicht ob sie
diesen Eindruck teilen dass wir seit
Januar 22 diesem Graphen folgend immer
unter die Mittel dieser vier Jahre
liegen mal unabhängig davon dass das
jetzt eben im Oktober und im November
kippen kann und das ist auch ein ganz
kalter Winter werden kann darf man kann
man den Menschen unterstellen dass sie
dazu sorglos her drauf hätte umgehen mit
ihren Energiequellen dass wir
verschwenden also ich glaube diese
Grafik ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür dass
ein Preis eine Signalwirkung hat und ein
eine Verhaltensänderung herbeiführt wir
haben ja nicht jetzt erst seit zwei oder
drei Monaten so hohe Energiepreise
sondern im Prinzip ging das ganze ja
schon im letzten letzten herbstlosen und
ich glaube wir sehen da eine Reaktion
drauf und
es ist glaube ich auch so ein bisschen
aus dem Erlebnis unseren Unterhaltungen
die wir privat führen und so also es ist
doch überall Thema und ich glaube schon
dass man da in gewisser Weise auf die
Menschen hoffen kann und auch auf die
Einsichtsfähigkeit und ich meine wenn es
natürlich auch wirklich schmerzt dann ja
klar werden die Leute natürlich weniger
verbrauchen dafür kennt noch mal Frau
Oehlmann gibt es Menschen also
unterstellt man zu Recht Bürgern dass
sie nachlässig damit sind dass sie
darüber noch nicht nachgedacht haben das
sieht sich das jetzt erst bewusst machen
oder sagen sie nee eigentlich also
bewusst ist es allen und ich glaube auch
dass alle drüber nachdenken die
Schlussfolgerungen sind nur sehr
unterschiedlich wir haben Menschen die
schon komplett alles eingespart hatten
weil sie vorher mit der Kohle und der
Corona schon nicht mehr zurecht gekommen
sind vielleicht Nebenjob aufgehen
mussten für die Kinder und so weiter und
so fort die können gar nichts mehr
einsparen wir haben die Menschen die im
Prinzip lange gut zurechtgekommen sind
und jetzt die Preissteigerung nicht mehr
gewuppt bekommen und auf einmal vom
großen Problem stehen wir haben aber
auch die Menschen die jetzt richtig
investieren und sagen unter Heizlüfter
und des Notstromaggregat im Garten und
zwar wasserfest damit ich im Zweifel
auch nichts verzichten muss also wir
haben auch da eine große Bandbreite was
ich aber in der Verbraucherzentrale auf
allen Ecken und Ebenen mitkriege sind
wirklich dass die Menschen sich Gedanken
machen und auch bereit sind zu sanieren
Geld auszugeben damit Sie Ihren Beitrag
wieder für die Gesellschaft leisten und
sagen und ich verbrauche am Ende weniger
also hilft es der Gesellschaft für
kommen weiter okay auch selber
unabhängiger zu werden also wir haben
hier in Berlin ein solarförder Hinweis
unterstützt wenn Menschen auf ihre
Dächer im Solarzellen aufbringen wollen
die Nachfrage ist riesig die hat sich
verdoppelt wir haben gar nicht da ist
dann wieder die Grenze die das
Fachpersonal was die Solaranlagen dann
auf das Dach bringt aber die einspar
Notwendigkeit wird denke ich schon
gesehen die Frage ist nur geht es auch
immer über in echtes handeln und ich
glaube da müssen wir auch sagen wir
müssen erstmal auch mit gutem Beispiel
vorangehen wir haben hier für die
öffentliche Verwaltung auch mal einfach
angefangen seid okay ja auch wir müssen
ja mit der Wirtschaft gesprochen eine
Karte fürs Energie sparen mit der
Berliner Wirtschaft abgeschlossen mit
Arbeitsplatz sie sollen auf jeden Fall
die Lichter brennen lassen an
Weihnachten das kann ja auch gerne
passieren aber es kann eben nicht sein
dass wir auf der einen Seite sagen wir
sparen und machen Entlastungsmaßnahmen
und finanzieren dann mit öffentlichen
Geldern für eine viertel Millionen
Weihnachtsbeleuchtung das machen wollen
können Sie das tun ja aber Festival of
Lights wird auch in Berlin stattfinden
aber ist privat finanziert und auch mit
energiesparkonten
eine Grafik wenigstens die
interpretationsfähig ist die Bürger
kriegen gerade die ganze Zeit gesagt
dass sie zu wenig tun dass wir sie zu
wenig tun das sieht zu wenig tun kommt
einem das ein bisschen bekannt vor aus
corona-zeiten da hatten die Menschen
auch längst reagiert und die Politik hat
immer noch später reagiert ehrlich
gesagt als die Menschen und wir haben
nicht verstanden dass die Leute in
diesem Land auch von sich aus vernünftig
sind ja die Leute sind von sich aus
vernünftig absolut ja das ist mit
Sicherheit so und deswegen glaube ich
schon dass wenn jetzt die Heizperiode
beginnt dann wird man es bei den
Privathaushalten ja erst sehen was
signifikante Einsparungen anbelangt aber
in der
Öffentlichkeit aber in der
Marktwirtschaft ist es halt eben so dass
das Verhalten auch über den Preis
gesteuert wird deswegen kommt es ja
darauf an dass man da einen klugen Mix
am Ende findet aber Frau ellner ich
finde man muss schon auch noch über was
zweites sprechen also wir sprechen
darüber wie indust im Handel und Bürger
Energie einsparen sollen das ist auch
richtig aber umgekehrt und auch wenn wir
so viel Geld ausgeben um die Härten
abzudämpfen muss man auch darüber
sprechen dass man wirklich alle
Potenziale nutzen und da kann man
beispielsweise über den Biogas Deckel
sprechen da kann man immerhin sehr
schnell zwei Millionen Haushalte
zusätzlich mit Strom versorgen und ich
kann es ihnen nicht ersparen man muss
auch über eine längere Laufzeit von
Kernkraftwerken sprechen
aber ich finde das eine gehört zum
anderen also wir sprechen über eine
gasmangellage wir sprechen über
notwendige Einsparungen das ist alles
richtig aber dann muss auch die Politik
alles tun um eine solche Mangellage
wirklich zu verhindern und dann sind wir
bei dem Thema was tatsächlich als
nächstes auch in der Luft liegt nämlich
zu sagen sie wollen noch mal zum Sparen
okay ganz kurz also wenn man sich die
Kurve anschaut dann kann man sich
ungefähr vor wissen wie viel davon den
Haushalten im Juli August gekommen ist
weil die verbrauchen ja kaum was also
das war wirklich vor allen Dingen eben
die Industrie dann auch und das sind
wenn man jetzt den September anschauen
nicht 20 Prozent und 20 Prozent ist das
was von fast allen als Minimum angesehen
wird was was wir fahren müssen gut da
ist aber erst noch einiges zu leisten
also das definitiv die die
trotzdem haben wir uns getraut mal
deutlich zu machen dass wir tatsächlich
mit den Verbrechen unter dem und das ist
ja eine in der Öffentlichkeit sein eine
Behauptung dass wir mit den Verbrechen
bisher in 22 unter diesem Mittel liegen
wir sind bei dem Thema von Herrn Frey
und das ist wichtig es gibt nämlich
nicht nur die Opposition sondern es gibt
ganz viele Unternehmer es gibt ganz
viele Wirtschaftswissenschaftler die
sagen
unser Angebot an Energie ist zu gering
es muss jetzt alles an die Front was wir
haben weil auch ein größeres Angebot an
Gas und Strom würde Preise senken und
schon machen wir die Runde wer möchte
anfangen Frau Pickel ist mit Sicherheit
richtig wir müssen nur sehen wo kriegen
wir das Angebot tatsächlich her also
bei Bioenergie gab es auch mal Gründe
warum man den Deckel tatsächlich auch
eingeführt hat da muss man sich
überlegen ob man den jetzt aktuell noch
aufrechterhalten will oder nicht das ist
mit Sicherheit so aber es gibt dann
natürlich auch wiederum die Frage was
baue ich an baue ich Energiepflanzen an
oder baue ich im Prinzip auch
Lebensmittel an was jetzt in der
aktuellen Situation vielleicht auch
nicht ganz unwichtig ist also wenn ich
es aus Reststoffen mache bin ich sofort
bei Ihnen keine Frage das zweite ist
dass man auf Erdgas ja versucht das
Angebot tatsächlich hochzufahren also
ist wesentlich mehr nach Europa an
Flüssiggas reingekommen man hat es
versucht bei Pipelines also nicht so
erfolgreich und man baut jetzt oder
schafft an wie man immer das nennen will
die Flüssiggas die schwimmenden Terminal
wenn die kommen dann ist das schon mal
das schon mal viel mit gewonnen nicht
alles aber viel also ich denke die
Anstrengungen haben schon sehr lange
darauf fokussiert dass ich tatsächlich
das Angebot ausweite die Gespräche mit
allen Herren Ländern insofern finde ich
diese Fokussierung die wir etwas
Momenten mehr haben tatsächlich auch auf
die Nachfrage und auf einsparen finde
ich schon mal ganz gut weil wir haben zu
lange immer versucht das quasi das
wegzudrängen weil wir können ja mehr
importieren es ist interessant dass sie
sagen weil ich gerne noch mal drei
Wirtschaftswissenschaftler zu Gehör
bringen wollte die mit einem großen
warnen und mahnen nicht nur jeden Tag
anmahnen an dem wir noch nichts tun
sondern auch sagen dass es zu einem
nennenswerten notstandsverlust in diesem
Land kommt und auch vor einer die
Industrialisierung warnen
Deutschland steht im Winter vor einer
schweren Rezession bei gleichzeitiger
rekordinflation
auf Sicht der nächsten zwei Jahre ist
die Lage dramatisch es muss jetzt alles
daran gesetzt werden dauerhafte Schäden
durch eine drohende
d-industriealisierung abzuwenden
die Politik sieht das ganze Ausmaß der
Verarmung der Bevölkerung nicht weil es
aus den offiziellen Zahlen nicht
hervorgeht
letzterer war Gabriel felbermaier uns
nochmal zu sagen der verweist darauf
Herr drauf hätte dass das BIP die
Konjunkturprognosen nicht mit
berücksichtigen dass eben sich die
Preise erhöht haben in den Produkten die
die Menschen kaufen und deshalb weisen
die konjunkturinstitute 0,4 Prozent
Rezession aus fürs nächste Jahr und Herr
Felbermayer sagt es werden wenigstens
vier Prozent Kaufkraftverlust sein und
dieses Land wird
ärmer sein Frage an Sie wie groß werden
die Schäden sein wie groß wird
der Schaden für Deutschland sein
der Schaden ist groß der ist da weil wir
eben das Gas was wir immer so billig
bekommen haben aus Russland ersetzen
müssen durch teureres Gas das wird uns
dieses Jahr der Wirtschaftsminister
spricht davon 60 Milliarden ungefähr
kosten das wird im nächsten Jahr
vielleicht noch mal 100 Milliarden auch
sein das sind Dinge die hätten wir
natürlich in andere Dinge investieren
können die Unternehmen hätten damit die
Transformation beginnen können hin zu
erneuerbaren Energien und all diese
Dinge drohen jetzt natürlich liegen
gelassen zu werden deswegen ist es ja
auch so sinnvoll dass wir dass der Staat
jetzt die Bürger aber auch die
Unternehmen stützt denn ein Teil dieser
gaspreisbremse wird ja auch für die
Unternehmen genommen das wird sie nicht
von von allen Schäden praktisch
entlasten aber es ist auf jeden Fall ein
Anfang und was die Industrie jetzt
natürlich machen muss mit Unterstützung
des Staates ist eben den wahren
Wandel einzuläuten dann weg eben von
fossilen Energien von von Erdgas die uns
auf so eine fatale Weise tatsächlich
auch schon in Größenordnung getan hat
und jetzt in eine schreckliche Situation
kommt wir sind bei der Politik vor
Gefahr hier ist noch mal die Frage wie
groß ist ihre Sorge nicht nur um die
Berliner Industrie sondern um die
industrielle Basis dieses Landes wenn
nicht auch da wirklich schnell geholfen
wird was tun Unternehmer egal wie groß
sie sind sie vergleichen sich mit den
Chancen in anderen Ländern und sehen
dass da die Preise alle runter gehen mal
unabhängiges von den USA auch dahin
könnte man schauen also bei allem was
jetzt gemacht wird ist es essentiell
dass der Wohlstand der in den letzten
gerade auch Ostdeutschland sage ich das
ganz deutlich in den letzten über 30
Jahren seit dem Fall der Mauer auch
erarbeitet worden ist dass der nicht bin
weniger Monate den Bach runtergeht und
das bedeutet es braucht massive
Wirtschaftshilfen deswegen haben wir zum
Beispiel auch ich meine es ist eine
gemeinsame Kraftanstrengung das dürfen
wir nicht wissen es nützt gar nichts
immer dem einen und dem anderen zu sagen
also der Grund warum wir überhaupt in
der Lage sind es erstmal dieser
Angriffskrieg ja und jetzt müssen wir
versuchen in einer gemeinsamen
nationalen Kraftanstrengung dafür zu
sorgen dass wir unsere Wirtschaft retten
den Wohlstand bewahren Arbeitsplätze
sichern das heißt
Liquiditätshilfen auch eben diesen
diesen Deckel diese Bremse die jetzt
beschlossen dass es ein ganz wichtiger
Punkt ein echter die haben das muss ich
ganz schnell auch noch Fragen Frau
Giffey sie haben auch selbst für
Verwirrung gesorgt weil sie beim
Kollegen Markus Lanz von kontrollierten
Stromabschaltungen
[Musik]
hier ist das Zitat wenn man dafür an
bestimmten Stellen dann mal für zwei
Stunden für drei Stunden angekündigt auf
Strom verzichten muss dann ist das ein
Szenario das vertretbar ist ist ganz
wichtig dass man da den Anfang
betrachtet gebe ich Ihnen
am Anfang nein das ist so wir haben hier
in Berlin einen Stromnetz mit 36.000 km
ist so weit wie von hier bis nach
Neuseeland und zurück und dieses ist
organisiert in einer Wabenstruktur für
uns ist wichtig dass die einzelnen Waben
gut funktionieren wenn wir eine
Situation haben das ist eine Überlastung
gibt weil alle ihren Heizlüfter
gleichzeitig den Backofen und die
Waschmaschine laufen lassen dann muss
man dafür sorgen dass die Anlagen nicht
überhitzen quasi und man dann in eine
Situation kommt in der die Anlagen
beschädigt werden denn das würde zu und
dann gibt es Grundlast ausgleichen
dazu da dass sie das aufklären können
wir reden nicht von Abschaltung sie
ahnen nicht davon was sie ausgelöst
haben weil Menschen kaufen tatsächlich
petroleum-kocher weil sie sich in
Stadtbezirken darauf vorbereiten wollen
dass wir haben das ganz vielfach erklärt
wir für uns ist wichtig
Energieversorgung ist gesichert unser
unsere Priorität ist die Anlagen müssen
geschützt werden wenn die Anlagen in
einer Wabe von vielen tausend zu
überlasten drohen dann kann man temporär
eine kleine Wabe vom Netz nehmen aber
nur dann als Schutz für die Anlagen
nicht als Maßnahme um Strom zu sparen
so etwas zu verhindern aber aus meiner
Sicht was was in dieser Situation auch
wichtig ist um auf ihre Ausgangsfrage
noch mal zurückzukommen das ist einfach
dass wir schauen dass wir die
Standortqualität weiter verbessern ich
finde es schon bemerkenswert wir haben
nicht nur neun Mal höhere Energiepreise
als in den USA sondern schon vor
Ausbruch des Krieges in der Ukraine
waren sie drei Mal höher bei uns
übrigens auch dreimal höher als in
Frankreich und ich merke das durchaus in
meinem Wahlkreis im Schwarzwald das
Unternehmen daran eben auch
Investitionsentscheidungen festmachen
also auch wenn wir uns mit anderen
Ländern in Europa vergleichen ist es ein
Problem und deswegen glaube ich brauchen
wir wenn wir sozusagen durch die Krise
durchschauen und die akuten Probleme
gelöst haben schon auch eine neue
Angebot Politik die sich auf die
Energiepolitik bezieht die sich auf die
Arbeitsmarktpolitik auf die
Steuerpolitik auf die
Wissenschaftspolitik beziehen damit wir
den Standort sicher machen für die
Zukunft und verhindern dass es zu
dauerhaft was die Regierung bietet wenn
wir bei der Energiebasis bleiben bei dem
Energieangebot Frau Pickel ist ja jetzt
zu sagen es auf your Switch geben es
soll die Möglichkeit geben dass Firmen
noch mal auf Öl zurück wechseln können
es sollen Kohlekraftwerke in diese
akuten Not dazu kommen und es soll eben
nun auch letzte Äußerung von Robert
Habeck wenigstens zwei Kraftwerke
Atomkraftwerke im Süden des Landes für
wenigstens drei oder vier Monate doch
nach stand jetzt weiterlaufen
sagen sie das rechtfertigt die Situation
weil es tatsächlich zu befürchten steht
dass unser Land Schaden nimmt oder sagen
Sie das ist eigentlich nicht gut und wir
sollten da jetzt hart durch
ich überlege jetzt ob ich die richtige
Frage richtig verstanden habe ja ich
denke das ist gutes jetzt zu machen gut
weil wir müssen in der kurzen in der
kurzen Zeit müssen wir jetzt sehen dass
wir durch diese Situation durchkommen
ohne dass es zu unkontrollierten
Blackouts kommt ohne dass es zu
unkontrollierten Abschaltungen im
Gasbereich kommt weil das darf man auch
nicht vergessen die Prognosen die jetzt
auch die führenden
Wirtschaftsforschungsinstitut und ifo
ist ja auch dabei herausgebracht haben
gehen davon aus dass wir die
Einsparungen schaffen an Energie wenn
wir die nicht schaffen dann steht auch
an der AFD eine anderen Seite das ist
dann bis zu 8% die Wirtschaft einbrechen
kann und das ist eine Hausnummer mit der
wir alle nicht umgehen wollen